lol saison
4 W c'est parti petit rappel des règles
au moindre rire c'est carton j'ai très
très peur fait entrer les concurrents
c'est pas plus faible en notoriété je
dirais pas ça c'est plus populaire ça va
partir dans tous les sens là regardez on
dirait mes couilles qui font la
bise moi je suis pas venu pour trier les
lentilles c'est la première fois je
pleure comme ça chis que je envie de
rire je vais dire je ris je ris je r Je
r Je r Je
r jeis bien la chatte ça ça me fait rire
vraiment on va vous passer un petit
extrait de musique on va rechanter
[Musique]
derrière c'est un
cl je vais vous présenter une danse
médiévale qui s'appelle appelle la
branle il est fou ce
mec tu as croqué ma
croquette
lol j'espère que vous aimer les fruits
parce qu'on va se fendre la
poire